in five four three two one hello
salutations welcome everybody to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
already know it's a Thursday so you bout
to hear some two dumb [ __ ] people
talk about some interesting [ __ ] man
genius bras genius bras babe a lift up
in support that's right we're gonna
start selling some genius bras baby
actually we support but we put down a
lot so maybe that's not the right thing
to say oh we're the natural bras all we
put down how do you put was something
that you put down and support Asian
children Asian gives you please I'm
parenting you put them down emotionally
but you still support them with your
money
Asian bras so oh did you wait were you
in Vietnam during the whole [ __ ]
boxing match with the ksi yeah I was i I
watched a little bit out there but I
know what's interesting what's the Nick
Diaz fight - who did you yeah both of
them was when i was in vietnam
vietnamese that [ __ ] was crazy huh yeah
it was a they was it was them doing a
pro [ __ ] match and they me I was at
Bart's house watching it and originally
I didn't want to watch it but it was
like you know why the [ __ ] not you know
yeah and I think it's kind of dope that
their training and their putting their
heart into it yeah and they've been
boxing out for two years
training with some of the best people
ever [ __ ] I found out that I guess like
because ksi trains with this guy named
Vidal I was like a UK dude anybody was
also training with Jeff went Mayweather
which wow yeah which is pretty cool and
then Logan Paul was training with
Shannon the cannon Briggs former
heavyweight champion crazy [ __ ]
mm-hmm and then watching the match and
you know it's weird because it's hard to
judge when they're boxing in front of a
huge crowd like that because I'm pretty
good gear yeah it's it's straight out
it's not a it's a full-on match you know
and they you know as the pro boxers of
course they suck their shitty Pro boxers
like it's their amateur boxer still but
they got to do the pro boxing thing
obviously through the zone and they're
not having headgear so it's considered a
pro boxing match but in terms of skill
levels I mean they know this about
themselves too
they're at an amateur level
and if they [ __ ] with any proboscis they
get the [ __ ] ass knocked out but
having said that it doesn't mean that
you know watching them improve from the
year before to now was pretty great like
they've they've gotten so much better
and it's kind of cool to see like people
who've never done boxing before be able
to do that on that type of stage I know
a lot of people felt weird about it
because it people who are really
hardcore purist boxing fans they think
it makes the sport look like a joke but
will those [ __ ] political like you
those scammy calls make them support
look controversy that they've been doing
with the corruption I mean that makes
the sport looks bad look bad and yeah I
don't know like gets new eyes on it I
understand what the zone is doing it
makes sense yeah but I was watching a
clip of afterwards and I wanted to see
some of their training footage just
because you know I love like fighting
yeah and that kid ksi men he looked and
when he was sparring he looked pretty
[ __ ] good man and compared to what he
was doing in that ring yeah he was
emotionally hype so he kept on going for
these telegraph haymakers yeah but when
he was sparring he looked great yeah
like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was this [ __ ]
when you were in the ring man but it's
different when the lights are on you
know when ding oh [ __ ] I just want to
knock out yup and I should let all out
the windows swing all day yeah like that
kid ksi he was he was he won right he
won yeah from being just throwing more
throws or uh I mean from the stats it
looked like I think what I read wasn't
you know don't quote me on this I was
really looking into it like that but I
think Logan threw more jabs and he
connected more but in terms of being
being effective so Logan lost a couple
of points because he did an illegal move
he hit him with a clean uppercut which
was [ __ ] dope it was actually a
really smooth move but afterwards he
grabbed the back of KS eyes head
uppercut at him which I don't think he
got a point Dean 2.4 but after he fell
he punched ksi in the back of his head
twice so it's like you know so they
deemed him two points and then he lost
but either way even if from what from my
point of view in terms of effectiveness
I thought ksi want and so even if there
wasn't a ding to it because they also
didn't get ksi a knockdown even though
he knocked Logan Paul behind his ear and
knocked him down cuz of the back of the
head thing if they say that was back of
a head when you look at the replay it's
not it's smack dab behind the ear
perfect it oh so did a great job but he
also didn't get points for that so
you know you call it either way at the
end of the day ksi won and it was a
great job
was it like dope boxing no it was it was
a it was a cool amateur match damn I
didn't see the whole thing they made
like four mil or some [ __ ] like that oh
my god I do for another get my ass beat
they're making more money than the pros
almost that feel I think we're just in a
different era man
yeah and that just goes to show like
people just want to watch and follow who
they love yeah they don't care how
[ __ ] talented you are okay it's a
different time dude I see a different um
it's kind of like you have the
old-school guys that are like man it's
all about the talent and this and then
you have the new-school guy that's like
knots about connecting with your fanbase
yeah I mean it's I mean definitely just
watching them improve was kind of cool
like I mean if you're a real boxing
friend you're gonna say that was shitty
boxing and of course it was they've only
been doing it for a couple of years
because they only care about this scale
yeah they you know you know a couple
years out and they're not they're not
multi-talented in this sport they're not
one of these like prodigy childs I think
a lot of people might feel like they
don't deserve it
yeah I mean if you're looking at it from
a sport perspective I could see that but
they also they're the ones who put the
asses in the seats so they could do
whatever the [ __ ] they want technically
yeah and there's no if you're gonna be
mad at somebody be mad at the zone
there's only the one that put them up in
the ring they're the one that sponsored
it yeah so if don't be mad at them be
mad at [ __ ] his own well I don't I
don't feel any way about those two
people but it's it's really their
fanbase I think it was a little weird
because the undercard was um one person
who I actually really liked who trains
out of the mayweather gym [ __ ] Devon
Haney he was he had a title fight an
actual [ __ ] title fight and it was the
undercard Wow or the Logan poly case I
match so the undercard was a title fight
for the exhibition match what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy huh Wow the hell just the
world is changing man it's crazy
those two are so [ __ ] yoked though
they were jacked beyond belief really so
uh would they get tested for steroids I
don't know I'm thinking I test for
steroids and they're kind of young to
leave it could be natural I don't know
like Logan was getting a little pink and
red I don't know if that's a white
person thing or that was just because of
his he might've been doing some TRT I'm
just I'm just speculating I know a lot
of influencers are really
that steroid [ __ ] though yeah so I
wouldn't be surprised if they were yeah
I know a lot of guys that aren't fitness
gurus they're just like Instagram guys
bloggers all that like they do enhance
[ __ ] like the girls do enhance [ __ ] like
everyone's doing it for the gram and
like whatever I'm not about it cuz I
don't know like to me I don't know like
it's not my world you know but I know
personally they do it and yeah that's
not a hater thing either like I'm
talking about it's a lot of people do
steroids you know I mean like I always
wonder what it's their choice to me it's
like if you want to get plastic surgery
that's on you all this stuff that's on
them it's just not my style yeah I don't
I could give two [ __ ] less about it
yeah I rather just work out try to be
healthy have fun but that's their thing
you know it's like their some of them
their image is their career they banked
on being cute they beg they banked up
being sexy all these things like and
they've profited a lot from it man it's
crazy but this industry makes so much
[ __ ] money man it's crazy do you know
some of these girls like on just because
I know people who work for the companies
that sponsor some of these girls top the
amount of money they make is unreal like
women can sell so if anybody out there
that wants to be an influencer now this
is not this is not to say that you'll be
in this bracket there this is a very
small bracket people who get to make
this type of money mm-hmm but I know a
girl who she models some type of swimmer
and then she does like some fitness
other [ __ ] too and they're paying her
like seven five grand a month to post
like four times four times a month
mm-hmm it's like [ __ ] oh you know some
top people that get a hundred thousand
proposed yeah it's it's naughty that's
it's ridiculous right so this is you're
talking about out of average average
person like not not like on the crazy
high tier yeah and you know she's making
a cool 12 15 16 grand a month just
posting you know photos of her wearing
certain clothing when it comes to
influencing and all that stuff I feel
like women have better marking like when
it and and and like if they keep their
[ __ ] clean like they get bigger dollars
yeah like I have me and Bart's level
falling in whatever like we're lucky if
we get the same amount of money as a
girl that has 80,000 followers yeah
it's completely different girls have a
very interesting take in it and I say
this for just from experiences from
working with brands it's like how I put
it as is guys want to [ __ ] them girls
want to be them yeah and they have so
much selling and buying power it's
unreal man and and I think women just
tend to spend more on improving
themselves and all that stuff guys are
actually more frugal unless it comes to
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah guns yeah
[ __ ] camera equipment for me yeah you
know it's more like that right so if I'm
endorsing that product or gaming
products or whatever like if that was my
fan base I kill it yeah for sure but
it's like there no one knows how to what
to do with me Hey Hey Joe can you make
this soap funny all right [ __ ] it I'll
do it and I could definitely make that
so funny yeah I'll do it I'll do
whatever now I don't give a [ __ ] man
it's just a nature of things cuz you
know YouTube is just it's killer like we
lost half of our income on YouTube so
[ __ ] it we got to move on to different
things you know dude I I saw this other
article too were there I don't know who
this youtuber is but he's really really
popular it's like David it's like Don
Rick or something like that or this
podcast is brought to you by attitude if
you have an amazing mattress what good
is an amazing mattress without some
amazing sheets to go with it now if
you've had cotton sheets before or any
other fabric then you are missing out if
you haven't had clean lovely bamboo
sheets and that's what attitude has I've
been sleeping on my attitude sheets for
quite a while and I got to tell you I
sleep butt naked and um I need the
fabric that touches my blessed skin to
be amazing and I'm not kidding you I
actually do sleep butt-naked in the
sheets that I use our attitude I
personally love these sheets not
scratchy it feels amazing and on top of
that it keeps me really cool I run hot
and I need my sheets to match the
amazing mattress that I have if I have a
dope mattress and I don't have a great
sheet then what's really the point right
it's like having shoes but not having
these shoe laces to keep your feet in
yeah that's how important it is so check
this out
with your attitude products let's talk
about this
Organic clean bamboo is extremely
breathable it regulates her temperature
like I just mentioned to improve your
quality of sleep it's antimicrobial
customers have claimed that their skin
appearance improved after switching to
edit two sheets yes
read the reviews yourself so why not try
attitude these amazing sheets have a
30-day risk trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your sheets for
a full refund
they even cover shipping on returns so
edit two sheets their softest silk
breathable less linen but at the price
of cotton you or that special someone
you buy them for are going to love them
and right now my listeners will get 20%
off their sheets set and free shipping
just text brain to six four zero zero
zero the only way to get 20% off your
set of attitude sheets and free shipping
is the text brain to 64000
text be are AI n - 6 4 - 0 0 0 Oh
dobrik dobrik david dobrik yeah yeah a
some really popular youtubers yeah I
like some of his [ __ ] yeah yeah what
does he do bugs life vlogs oh that's all
he does that's cool you know it's just
him and his friends and it's funny like
every single video is 4 minutes and 20
seconds oh really yeah 20 this yeah and
it's in every single thumbnail as his
face like going like has a big eye and
[ __ ] and it reminds me a little bit of
like old school like fun vlogging were
you and your friends just [ __ ] around
and there's just snippets like imagining
like vine snippets yeah
compiled together of 4 minutes and it's
just like one second they're playing a
board game and laughing the next second
they're like drawing on their friend the
next second they're like in a grocery
store [ __ ] around so to me I mean
it's wholesome its wholesome enough you
know yeah but but he put out an article
talking about how much he was making
before ad pocalypse and what he makes
now I'm not sure how true it is just
because the amount that he said he was
making is around the same time but the
man that I was making which I make way
less views yeah cuz he averages he says
he makes more views now than he did
before but after ad pocalypse because of
the type of content that he has that he
makes an average of $2,000 a month now
are you kidding on his channel but Wow
but I don't know how much views he made
but he was talking like he makes
millions of you still he he does yeah he
says he makes like $2,000 a month which
I find highly impossible he might be
getting to monetized maybe all of his
videos were demonetized then huh
yeah it may be I don't know what it is
but they may be de menthe eyes all of
his videos he says you should make
that's crazy
he said he used to make 250 grand a
month and they went from 250 grand a 2
grand a month [ __ ] crazy dude I made
250 thousand dollars a month he did oh I
thought you said I used to make the same
amount no two thousand a month oh yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] that's that's how much I
make doc I would abate $250,000 I would
love that [ __ ] no I mean you're right
though at apocalypse we're making like
and you were from 10,000 at $20,000 a
month yeah and now we're lucky if we
make 2,000 a month yeah so people really
don't know how bad ad pocalypse
algorithms all these things has changed
right and I don't really blame YouTube
for it cuz I know people a part of the
team I know people that work at Facebook
Instagram all this stuff and they're in
the middle really trying their [ __ ]
best man like I talk [ __ ] and I say [ __ ]
YouTube and [ __ ] the algorithms and all
that but if I had to be like very honest
about it and and and Frank it's like
what are they suppose they're trying
their [ __ ] best right and there's
just so many moving pieces and they want
to please the creators they want to
please the government they want to
please the advertisers they they're
pulled in so many different directions
and I think the problem is all of these
social media sites they weren't prepared
for how [ __ ] big it was gonna be and
how much responsibility it was gonna be
like it was working because if you think
about it right within the last 10 years
YouTube is as important as the
television yeah and can you imagine like
how [ __ ] like quick that [ __ ] is in
10 years in 10 years you're like a
telephone or in 10 years like your you
know government is telling you hey you
have
to be [ __ ] professional like things
take a long time in order for that to
build but that should happen overnight
and what the guys tell me is like all
right so this is what's happening right
now right like yes there's D
monetization censorship and all this
stuff and it's getting kind of crazy in
egos but check it out would you rather
have us regulating or the government cuz
what's happening right now is like you
know how Facebook is on trial and all
that [ __ ] and they're pressing
Zuckerberg and that is gonna be whatever
happens there is gonna trickle down and
happen everywhere in social media they
don't know how to determine what social
media is right they're like is it a
monopoly well not really because anybody
could build a Facebook yeah but it's the
standard cuz everyone uses Facebook or
Google or whatever right and they're
like what's their responsibility is
their responsibility to like is it like
a phone company right so if a phone
company if if I say a racist word on
that or whatever the phone company
doesn't get in trouble maybe I do for
saying it on the phone right
but in YouTube's case YouTube gets in
trouble if there's a Isis beheading
video or whatever right so the
government's coming in and be like you
[ __ ] better control that [ __ ] or else
we'll come in and and control it for you
so they're like oh [ __ ] well when does
government intervention ever help
anybody yeah it's kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] up
because you know we all been to DMV we
all we all been to the IRS website the
IRS websites horrible a health care
website it's horrible
imagine what the legal system it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] up the ass man why do you
want government to come in I don't want
them to come in so they're doing their
best and they're doing the best thing
for them is just like hey that's that
that might be dangerous there's just if
I can take it down that might be
dangerous just [ __ ] take it down
they're just overreacting because they
don't know they don't have the capacity
in the foot traffic so they just use
BOTS right well and in the BOTS so just
shut down his video that that's too
risky shut down this video
whatever this [ __ ]
that you posted on Instagram we gotta
[ __ ] shut it down before the
government sees it so they're
overreacting because they're trying to
get their BOTS right now to learn and do
a human's job and then they hired like a
[ __ ] ton employees to review it know
that and I'm not trying to defend them
I'm just trying to explain the things
that people don't talk about or know cuz
I know the insider [ __ ] yeah
and this is the this is kind of like
their dilemma of how they're trying to
go by doing this it's a it's a lot more
intelligent than the way that I'm
[ __ ] explaining it but that's the
gist of it right and here we are the
creators and we're just like oh man
where the [ __ ] the money go though yeah
but also a lot of these old brands you
know like if you think about who
controls advertising dollars they're ran
by dudes that are like over 60 years old
yeah and a lot of those money still goes
to traditional media a lot of that [ __ ]
goes to Superbowl campaign kind of [ __ ]
and like a very small fraction of that
budget goes to digital marketing yeah
and things are going to shift and change
eventually there's gonna be more money
that goes into YouTube but in the
meantime a lot of it still goes to
stupid-ass TV commercials stupid as
newspapers [ __ ]
stupid ass [ __ ] like it's just [ __ ]
and dumb dude yeah you know a great
example of that is actually when so
prior to us starting our matcha business
we franchised a gelato pop business bar
and we were running into an issue with a
disagreement and how we should advertise
our store right and mind you was a part
of a franchise but the original deal
that we had was that we had flex and how
we wanted to advertise the product that
was how it was yeah and let me just give
an example of how dated it was they
wanted us to run ads on newspapers yeah
[ __ ] newspapers and at the time 2017
yeah who the [ __ ] is reading newspapers
grandpa this huh he wanted us to run
newspaper ads because the Instagram
stuff and the social media stuff wasn't
going to work
because he goes I know newspapers
because he came from a newspaper he was
originally like a top dog in a newspaper
[ __ ] a company yeah but and also like
the product it's a young hip exact
demographic it's like you're so [ __ ]
disconnected man and also like a lot of
them you know there's something called
brand association which I think the
archaic psychology behind it is like hey
I don't want my product tainted by like
your you know negative persona or
whatever right like coca-cola like they
might be like hey man like our views
don't match yours or whatever right
that's all changing yeah because thugs
need to eat to Foggs need to drink to
you know like whatever like like [ __ ]
everybody needs to do it right but this
is the stupid part they don't want your
product associated with negativity or
whatever because in people's minds
they'll start to associate that and
there's just all psychology behind it
but but here's the thing we're a big
part of pocalypse right it started with
a PewDiePie thing and we [ __ ] that up
because we didn't really understand it
but what the media was saying or the
traditional media was saying is like
look at how dangerous it is to post ads
on YouTube like and then they got like
Admirals on Isis beheading video they
got some Nazi content they got that you
know PewDiePie in the mix and all that
and they're like look like when you're
on YouTube and Google Adsense you can't
control where your ad goes do you really
want your ads to be supporting this
neo-nazi [ __ ] and then a lot of the ads
were like oh [ __ ] yeah scary and then
they pulled out of Google they pulled
out a [ __ ] advertising on YouTube and
[ __ ] and yeah I think it was a move from
traditional media because they were
losing money to digital media and they
[ __ ] did that so all of these guys
would freak out and pull out and in
there like YouTube you had to figure out
your [ __ ] and that's when the D
monetization started happening for us
yeah because they're like oh that's
dangerous like advertisers don't want to
be on a video of two girls in a cup
like they don't want to be able to deal
with us maybe talking [ __ ] about
politics or like this or that like
there's hella parameters right you know
all that [ __ ] went down but the stupid
[ __ ] is there's so much lack of
communication at YouTube for example
like someone like CNN when the Las Vegas
shooting happened right this was a huge
controversy like they'll [ __ ] run ads
on those videos with no sweat it's okay
but Casey nice that did a charity thing
for the Las Vegas shooting he got
demonetised they couldn't run ads and
then they told him we don't want a
profit off a tragedy but it's like what
a [ __ ] hypocrite yeah
you let CNN do that [ __ ] cuz CNN CNN
that's why exactly but it's the CNN
YouTube channel yeah or the Jimmy Kimmel
YouTube channel so it's like you guys
are [ __ ] this up because you can't be
you can't the point is you can't lie
yeah you can't lie to the creators and
be like hey we don't want you to profit
off this and they just gotta say like
check this out like we have an agreement
with CNN and it's all streamlined so
that you know to me that works well at
least for me it works right or you could
tell Casey nice that like hey sorry but
this you have a big channel um let's
streamline it the way that we have it
was CNN well just [ __ ] do that but
that's where a lot of the issues came to
play because people don't want to see
that hypocrisy like they don't want to
see that they don't want to see special
treatment especially because YouTube was
a platform for the people you know it
was it was for yo you could put up your
content however you want and however you
like it but just like with anything else
once money comes into it that the rules
change and then the bigger it gets the
rules change
exactly and who's like who it depends
like who's whose hand is in whose
pockets right now yeah right because if
if Google is getting paid by these big
advertisers and they're like yeah we're
gonna back out because we don't like
they're like okay well let me figure out
how to suck your dick now yeah cuz
they're gonna have to figure that out
because they need the money to survive
exactly and we're just getting the [ __ ]
in of the stick because it's like you
know when it all start
it was super small-scale we were under
the radar but then you know the bigger
we become the more professional we have
to be yeah and we got and I was [ __ ]
and I was okay with not being that's why
I started the patreon that's why I
started going to podcast just because
it's just I don't like being censored um
especially because I'm not really
spewing hate speech or anything yeah
like this is all just in comedy and in
jest and it's topics and I also I'm okay
with people disagreeing with me so that
is what it is but it got weird when it
was like people who had worse content
than I did we're getting money they were
allowed to monetize and I wasn't and I
was like just because it's favoritism
that we don't exist we're buried in the
millions of content creators this
podcast is brought to you by skill share
my friends listen if you are all about
life long learning outside of the
traditional way of learning I'm talking
about college and stuff like that I am
somebody that likes to learn at my own
pace and there are things outside of a
traditional education that I want to
learn and I want to do it in an online
space well that's why you have
Skillshare my friends now listen to me
skill share is an online learning
community with thousands of amazing
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills you could take
classes in everything from photography
creative writing to design productivity
and a lot more for me for a very long
time now I've actually been using it for
video editing and photography which is
something that I personally love is
something that I do for a living and
there's nothing wrong with me brushing
up all my skills and my basics and
Skillshare has a huge library for me to
pick and choose from for the stuff that
I want to learn in my respective area
which is photography and videography so
Skillshare has been helping me out and
it's such a great tool to use and you
can use it whenever you want so if you
sign up for Skillshare i'm telling you
man it's all about that lifelong
learning and delving into these stuff
that could be hobbies or maybe even
something more in the future but you'll
never know until you try skills sharing
my friends so check it out join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get 2 months of
Skillshare for free that's why
Skillshare is offering genius brain
listeners too much
of unlimited access to thousands of
classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash brain again go to
Skillshare comm slash brain to start
your two months now
that's Skillshare dot-com slash brain
yeah but what sucks is that the way that
the algorithm is now like we used to
have videos pop up to our subscribers
all the time yeah but the way that they
do it now is [ __ ] up man so if your
video doesn't get any traction within
the first hour it doesn't show up in
your subscribers list and when your
video shows up on your subscribers list
within the first hour it doesn't go to
all of them they'll be like they'll
probably release so for example they'll
release it to like this selected 100
that the robot thinks of right and let's
say out of 50 of those hundreds click ok
that's a 50/50 kind of thing maybe
they'll share it maybe they won't if 90%
of them click they'll be like oh this is
a trending video let me show it to a
thousand let me show it to this and then
that's why they'll pop up on recommended
and all that because they think that
this video is worthy of being watched
yeah but like wait like like with
anything that doesn't determine the
content of something right you might
have a dope thumbnail it might have some
kind of like title it might have like so
many different factors that make people
click and stick but it works for them so
it's fine but it's to me it's like it's
a stupid way to say you want quality
content people are just gonna figure out
ways to game it yeah and then it's like
I want my subscribers to see what they
signed up for yeah and people are like
hey this video didn't show up this video
didn't show up so it makes things harder
you know definitely harder but I learned
to not complain about it it's like
understand it and win the game that's
all it is
yeah it just things are gonna
continuously keep changing also too
because this stuff is a park to what it
is you know I mean like and also any
type of platform to it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't promised to us that we were
gonna make a living off of this it was a
it was a gamble that we tell you
everything is a plus
yeah I feel grateful yeah very [ __ ]
grape yeah and I got you know I'm
allowed to get irritated in mad when
especially when I can't [ __ ] pay my
bills yeah but you know it also taught
us to innovate and change and then you
know kind of reach out to these fans who
have been getting free content for years
and years and years and be like yo can
you donate like a dollar to you know to
keep this up if you guys was content if
not the night to change the content and
you know there's people who are
supporting that so yeah it's it's really
dope man and I and I kind of you know
there's a lot of appreciation there yeah
I mean there's ways to stay creative
because I always say like when people
know you
they can't unknow you hmm and if you
left a good impression on people then
they don't want to stick with you
because they enjoy what you create right
and I like Gary V's philosophy of like
give give give and then ask cuz I always
thought like you have to prove yourself
to people people before they spend their
hard-earned cash on you well and we've
cultivated such a [ __ ] loyal fanbase
man like I think our fanbase
specifically people that just follow you
or me or that we have a lot of crossover
fans right yeah and they are some of the
most loyal [ __ ] downest [ __ ]
on earth and I see my other creator
friends and they don't have they have a
[ __ ] fanbase a very fickle like people
just want to be like dance monkey dance
like I wonder why that is like what
happened like what how do they not
develop a connection to the people that
support them because when I found out -
especially you know just doing a lot of
stuff for advertisers they told me that
I have a very high conversion rate and
but I don't have nearly the amount of
views or following so it's it's because
I think you don't do flash entertainment
yeah which is like things that are like
really oh and AH you know you watch and
you go oh and then uol is interesting
and then like something that's very
viral and topical right like this is
very apparent to people this style I
think is very niche it's very deep
there's a lot of substance but it's not
easy entertainment yeah so like for
example like
some guys will go super [ __ ] viral
right and they'll have their stint but
after a while people will forget who
they are yeah why because they'll have
gimmicks they're like a one-trick pony
they have things that make you go oh man
that was a dope back flip and then
that's it you know and then you go
what's that gonna leave like like 20 20
[ __ ] best restaurants in this area
like that's dope I would watch it really
quick but if you have nothing of
substance to say in your video
in-between something to draw me into
your life something that makes you go
this place is this [ __ ]
interesting and you know what he reminds
me of me or my cousin and like you're
right man like this is [ __ ] dope so
not only am i watching this guy II in
substance I can in their substance in
the video it's like there's relatability
there's just like this is [ __ ] cool I
love this person I want to be this
person's friend I want this person to
mentor me they don't have that mmm we're
in our situation how many times when we
had meet and greets and this is not even
to [ __ ] like gas ourselves up when we
have meet and greets people come in and
go you're like a big brother all the
[ __ ] that you talk about all the things
that you say like you [ __ ] give me
value you know and that is a different
relationship with the fan base that we
have out there then someone who is an
entertainer right someone who's like
they're honest like I don't know they're
they're dare to [ __ ] juggle for you
yeah then it's like you go wow that's a
dope entertaining moment but you don't
give me value in my life that way one of
the things that it really appreciated -
and how I got to understand that really
well was when I started up my patron I
didn't know what to put up on there for
content cuz it made me feel weird
because I was asking for help and I've
never asked for help you know monetarily
to keep his channel alive before because
I never had to if it made a certain
amount and I was breaking even that was
fine but then when I started losing like
2 grand a month I was like this channel
has to go away yeah like it has to go
away because I can't lose $2,000 a month
doesn't make any sense and so you know
when I asked for help and you know they
decide to help out I asked like you okay
what kind of hot big dude put up
whatever dude it doesn't [ __ ] matter
we're just doing this just to support
you so so we can have you know genius
brain and we could have this
then come out like damn but that's
really [ __ ] nice because I felt a lot
of pressure to like make like 30 videos
on the patreon a month or some [ __ ] you
know yeah but at the same time for them
they're like no we're just here to
support you that's what we do posting
like 24 videos on the [ __ ] patreon a
month I mean for you guys it makes more
sense because you guys have a full cast
you know it's just me like I got a yeah
that's a lot of work yeah I know the
cool thing is what the patron I've been
able to converse with them and ask them
for their opinion about stuff but yeah
the people who are giving me money and
they support me that means they know me
a probably lot better than I know myself
yeah so like I can watch and yes I can
ask questions it's like Gilly what do
you think about the series that I want
to start and do this one instead I got
we would love to see you do this and I
take that into account and I'm like oh
[ __ ] now you gotta [ __ ] me up cuz now
I'm thinking about oh maybe they are
right and it's not a bad thing it's
because I actually do value their
opinions yeah so it's like oh maybe
you're right maybe I'm looking at this
at a weird angle yeah they're [ __ ] that
fans help remind me yeah cuz like you
know we get lost in the south and then
it's like hey Joe remember that quote
you said on my work quote you know that
funny coat about this and I'm like oh
man thanks dude cuz uh I forgot to look
at life that way you know or what I'm
like I forgot I even said that [ __ ] yeah
like that's some wise words that have
yeah oh [ __ ] I guess I am [ __ ] wise
but it's pretty cool though like being
able to develop that fanbase and just
kind of watching what a lot of these
youtubers have done yeah on this pace is
crazy yeah when we first started doing
this stuff out nobody knew what YouTube
was and I remember it was I used to get
[ __ ] pissed off because I had to talk
these people who had big companies and
they would try to tell me what the value
of what my following was when they don't
even know what a [ __ ] damn thing that
I do yeah and you know they're like oh
well this stuff doesn't convert and it
did but they didn't know right yeah and
they would just shoot down and make fun
of you know new media influencers it's
it's because they're insecure yeah and
it's like that's funny because it seems
like you're you losing all your [ __ ]
television views they're coming over
watching out there panicking bro they
don't know what the [ __ ] to do
yeah and instead of combining forces
they wanted to shut down new media and
now look at another knocking on new
media's door like okay well let's put up
our TV clips on YouTube so we can get
more traction for our stuff it's like
clearly remember you guys saying that
new media was gonna disappear yeah
I remember that [ __ ] where are you now
[ __ ] geezer yeah
and that's that's my thing is I hope I
never turned into that geezer because
I'm at that age we're like we connect
with young folks but we also connect
with old folks we're right in the
[ __ ] middle man yeah we're at that
middle middle point we're not in midlife
crisis but we're at that middle point
because like we're young we still look
young enough and cool enough to like
relate with like the [ __ ] high school
college kids and [ __ ] right yeah but
worse but we're old enough to be
respected and do business with sixty
year olds and [ __ ] right so we couldn't
walk into a [ __ ] boardroom or
whatever and we can also like walk into
a meet and greet and we get to
experience it all but I do start
understanding why old folks can get
stuck in their ways because you get kind
of comfortable and you miss your era and
you miss like the [ __ ] that back in my
day I see myself thinking I should all
the time cuz like cancel culture of
today [ __ ] socialism of today like
just different schools of thought that
I'm that's taking over and I feel like
oh man this is kind of weird only
because I was a [ __ ] communist in
high school a hardcore communist red
Communist Manifesto [ __ ] studied Karl
Marx like I was like hard hard left
right and these [ __ ] come out
here pretend communism they're just
pretend [ __ ] like it's a style to
them bro like I'm like what the [ __ ] you
guys don't even know what the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is like you're a wannabe liberal
and I know I went through my evolution
of that and I said you know what at the
end of the day I think I like being a
capitalist I think I like having power
in my decisions and being able to pay
like in and create a business and pay my
employees and do all that stuff like
that's what I want to do yeah I don't
want the government owning my business
or my property or nothing
you know like I don't want to share it
economy like I want people that's the
survival of the fittest and that's my
philosophy and I want that
freedom so like the you know for me
though like that that's just the era
that that we're living in
it's very polar so you either like hard
left or hard [ __ ] right the thing is
I'm not I'm in the middle right and I
have a preference but I also understand
where they're coming from but I don't I
think it's a dangerous thing and that's
kind of like the new era that we're
living in and I'm like mmm watch out
dude I used to think that way like I was
in that world and it didn't it didn't
turn out well like in it I don't think
there's ever an example of when it
turned out well yeah so be [ __ ]
careful but the young people like when I
was in high school was like yeah man why
isn't everyone just [ __ ] communist
why like these are the greatest things
like everyone should share equal [ __ ]
like these ideas man if people just
[ __ ] implement this [ __ ] the greed
the the problems all this [ __ ] will go
away the racism all this [ __ ] that's
what I believed in wholeheartedly and I
see it in the young folks of today
they're [ __ ] marching they're doing
all this stuff and then they're like
[ __ ] yeah socialism and all that and I'm
like mmm
damn dude watch out because that's how a
lot of countries kind of like got the
young people riled up and they're like
we believe in this [ __ ] we want a better
place we want a better society we got a
[ __ ] you know get together and make
this happen and there's a lot of tragedy
that's happened from those revolutions
and stuff like that so um I mean we're
getting into a touchy subject because
it's all personal yeah
ideals and preference like me I'm not a
thousand percent against it this is just
my theory right so like if if people
believe in it I respect you if that's
what you believe in I just think that I
I went through that cycle and that time
in my life and now I feel like the old
guy looking at them and instead of
relating to it and saying like oh I
remember that feeling
let me let me connect with you I feel
like the old guy going that was a [ __ ]
thing of the past
and I hate for you to be like that yeah
you don't mean like I see it as like Oh
it's almost like this it's almost like
an embarrassing moment in my past like I
was a raver that always did drugs right
don't go that route and I keep catching
myself doing that it's like oh you know
don't be a [ __ ] socialist or don't be
like this because you know I went that
path and [ __ ] I regret it
yeah and I don't think that's the best
way to approach it but I don't know why
I keep doing it yeah I mean I well when
we get older we kind of just get wiser
and wiser and wiser and it's hard to see
that that weird balance of him am I
being the old [ __ ] that's trying to talk
down to a young person or am I actually
trying to instill some [ __ ] wisdom
because yeah because we get caught up in
our own old ideals you know but at the
same time I don't I don't want you know
a young crowd to think that this is an
old head just talking to you my mom how
old but it's like you know there are
life experiences that we had that you
don't yeah and and you probably won't
listen but it's good that for for
somebody who's invested into you to say
it just so you have it in the back your
mind because that [ __ ] does come to
surface when you're older later I mean I
remember what it was like to to be young
and in these old [ __ ] go you'll
understand when you're old and you're
like shut up you [ __ ] outdated
thoughts yeah I've been all of a sudden
boom it hits you [ __ ]
right yeah and I mean that's the whole
thing too is like oh you got boomer
thoughts yeah [ __ ] boomer that's a
boomer mentality and I'm like man I'm a
millennial - you [ __ ] face like I'm in
the middle like I'm kind of in-between
and in and I see both sides well and
sometimes I'll choose the Boomer side
and sometimes I will choose the [ __ ]
millennial thought yeah it was such a
hard thing just to go back to the whole
media thing when um like I remember so I
got hired to interview this that this
this comic and he was getting a
late-night talk show and they were
trying to integrate new media with old
media right like TV [ __ ] and he was
getting show by the way his show tanked
and it's [ __ ] stuck so is what it is
you it was terrible and the guy was
super nice but I remember he got kind of
irritated at me because when I showed up
to interview him there was there was
supposed to be a packet that was sent to
me that had all of his information on it
so I could research it so I could ask
him questions and so they could put it
up for for media and promotion
and stuff right so whoever was my point
of contact didn't send me the packet and
it's not even though I was supposed to
receive one through my email showed in
the email I didn't get anything yeah I
show up to this thing that I hate do you
know who this like no like I was
supposed to be sent something I emailed
you guys about it you guys didn't hit me
back up so I didn't know what I've never
done one of these things before so where
was that Delano we send it to you and I
flipped up on my email my look it's not
that the oh I'm so sorry like we were
supposed to send you like this first of
all they were gonna send me an
informational DVD which was already
[ __ ] dated I can even I don't know if
I even had it has a DVD player now bro
that's what I'm saying man this was like
this was like seven years ago or so but
even then DVDs were outdated true so
they were gonna send me this
informational DVD yeah smart [ __ ]
move and I was like okay I guess and I
went there and I asked him a couple
questions and it wasn't supposed to be
the questions I was supposed to ask and
I look [ __ ] irritated at me cuz
you're supposed to memorize questions
yeah and then I remember when it was off
as like a bro like I'm supposed to know
[ __ ] about you but I wasn't sent [ __ ]
like so I know you're upset but don't
don't look at me like I [ __ ] up yeah I
whoever my point of contact was didn't
send me anything he was like yeah okay
whatever you know he could tell he was
really buying the story so I want to
talk to them my my my point of contact
yeah bro what the [ __ ] was that you just
sent me in there I don't have anything
to ask him right yeah and then later on
he's just apologizing his ass off and
this just goes this is a [ __ ]
dog-eat-dog type of world especially in
entertainment afterwards I got flack
from this from his television company
saying that I was unprofessional that I
didn't that I didn't do what I was asked
and I was like you didn't send me the
[ __ ] that I asked for most no one wants
to take blame cuz no one wants to lose
their job exactly and so I just had to
take the hit from it yeah and this whole
[ __ ] TV network looked at me like I
was some kind of young douchebag that's
just this new media [ __ ] I know you're
the old [ __ ] that [ __ ] up your job
yeah like you [ __ ] up I was doing my
job I asked for that [ __ ] multiple times
and you didn't send it [ __ ] pieces of
[ __ ] yeah and so I remember that I was
so [ __ ] pissed I was like [ __ ]
traditional television dude yeah like
YouTube is the [ __ ] thing cuz I don't
have to go through this red tape no and
you're your own boss yeah so it's like
yeah we'll have to do and roll with the
punches but also I can't deal with petty
[ __ ] and coward employees yeah like
I can't deal with office politics
because for me
there's too much conniving maneuvering
yeah and from it's like
if I'm gonna deal with that I rather
have I rather be the [ __ ] boss of the
company
yeah it just to let you guys know how
fickle entertainment is if you've if you
if you ever walk up into my position
where you can walk up into like Viacom
and all the so that other companies and
you know have these meetings not saying
that it's gonna go anywhere they may be
that meetings with everybody every time
I walk into these companies you're after
year all the employees change yep oh
yeah all the employees there's times
we're ok this the [ __ ] we would do a
pitch for a TV show and a month later we
would have to walk right in because it's
a different [ __ ] you know person
right on the show it's like who's this
it's like all that person's gone we have
a new person I've seen CEOs switch three
times for a major cable network in the
same [ __ ] years crazy
these guys are fickle [ __ ] Fox dude
yeah it is crazy dude and in like um I
was talking to a our producer at the
time remember the guy that was helping
us develop the show
he's [ __ ] cool man yeah and then he
was he was basically filling me in on
what's going on with cable TV they're
losing a [ __ ] ton of money it wasn't
what it used to be there's a lot of
poaching going back and forth back and
forth people getting [ __ ] signing
bonuses all this stuff there's a lot of
money to be going around because going
back to the ad story yeah a lot of those
ad dollars still go to traditional media
and then um no one really wants to take
responsibility but everyone wants to
take credit so yes here's the thing one
person will jump in get paid they'll be
like alright this this [ __ ] season
we're gonna change the game we're gonna
[ __ ] do they're gonna say some big
emotional speech about how it's all
about minorities this year right so they
they want all this minority content so
they bring us and we all pitch our shows
alright this is [ __ ] dope minority
show theirs and that this and that they
string us along they might spend a
little money for like uh not even a
pilot but like a little snippet real or
whatever what we did right yeah
they'll go back and all right you guys
want to buy the show and all this stuff
and they're like I don't know they don't
have that much money yeah
they seriously don't have money to
[ __ ] burn dude yeah I'm like dude
youtubers make more than just
you barely have [ __ ] money yeah
except when they actually get it it's
huge huge money like the pitch and all
that stuff is small but then when it
comes into like okay we're gonna shoot a
season of this it goes into the millions
and millions and millions yeah and then
that's when they get their [ __ ] break
and then that's when there's a lot of
money on the line and no one wants to
take responsibility and then here's this
other layer of [ __ ] up right so there's
like 20 people that can probably be
minimized to one person's job yeah love
to [ __ ] make things so inefficient
and the thing that I [ __ ] hate the
most is like you'll have ideas you have
scripts right but people have to justify
their position so you so this is the
thing that kills creativity right people
have to justify the position so like you
write a script you send it in and
everyone like it might be a solid script
someone might read it and go damn dude
this is dope a script I don't have
anything right on it but if you don't
have anything in write on it why are why
am I [ __ ] paying you yeah so you know
the script [ __ ] reader or the guy
that chooses it and everyone down the
line that's involved in the project they
want to give him their two cents hey you
know it'll be a good idea if you [ __ ]
add a clown why don't you put a clown in
your [ __ ] movie man why don't you do
this in your [ __ ] movie solidify
their position yeah so they were like
hey that was my idea I put that [ __ ]
clown in that movie yeah right
stupid-ass [ __ ] ideas or it'll be
like you need to take that line out you
know what you need to take that
character out and that was my idea
I did that right so this whole [ __ ]
[ __ ] of people are ripping away
on your script it was already good but
they have to justify it
they don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] yeah they
just want to keep their jobs so the
video gets made the product gets made
it's a shitty [ __ ] thing it could
have started off awesome and great
everyone guys to give give their [ __ ]
two cents everyone has to justify their
job so a lot of people that works in it
they get the game they know it's like a
lot of people are like and this happens
in marketing and everywhere everyone's
trying to give in their toes looking out
for their own ass yep there's no sense
of community of course I mean it's your
own job I understand but it's just a
different ecosystem and I don't think
that they're shady or anything it's a
different ecosystem that I don't
yeah and you know this is why when this
when these new when new blood comes in
they're gonna start changing up the game
a little bit which it has to happen soon
because a few years back I was also
working with this company and it was a
on a TV show that I was gonna sell but
there was a person who got replaced in
this cup and I hated this person so
[ __ ] much because it was somebody who
I know for a fact because I've seen it
so many times this person didn't do
anything and they got paid so much money
but so for example this is how arbitrary
this [ __ ] human being is and you know
I'm not I'm not an employee of that
company so you can't pull this [ __ ]
on me and when I tell you that I'm not
confrontational but I will call out
[ __ ] when [ __ ] being put on me
because you're wasting my [ __ ] time
yeah that shit's crazy it pisses me off
so for example it would be some [ __ ]
like this he goes hey David let's let's
let's hop on this conference call real
quick I need to well we could we could
set up a tie-in at 8 a.m. in the morning
and we could get on this conference call
I know and I would write back on the
email I was like wasting my time it's
like well it can it be done through
email or do we need to have a
conversation about this on conference
call because I'm busy so if you could
just write to me with your pitches on
email then let me let me think about it
and then let's hop on a call it goes no
man we gotta do it in person
cool calls me up right it goes eh bro so
this is the idea do you like it I'm like
yeah it's cool like oh man we'll talk
about with our team I'll hit you back up
and I was like hold on a second I
explicitly wrote to you on the email if
you could just write it to me
why did you why did I have to wake up at
8 a.m. in the [ __ ] morning to have
you asked me a question who could have
done that you know right yeah he goes oh
I just need to get that verbal
confirmation and I'm like bro this and I
didn't say this to him but it's him
pretending to work so his boss thinks
that he's working yeah that's why he's
doing the conference call because he
puts it in his schedule at his boss sees
oh did you just wake me up after I after
I just been editing a video till 5:00
[ __ ] a.m. to bring me up on a
conference call to ask me a [ __ ]
question for five seconds yeah and then
you know I got so annoyed to the point
where we were having these group calls
about the show idea and then we were
trying to develop it and then invited
this guy got fired by the way I knew
like a CEO came in and they did
evaluations on people they saw how lazy
he was yeah so this guy
I got so [ __ ] pissed I remember I was
on the phone call there was a couple
other people around me and big attend I
was irritated this guy because we'd
wrote an email and then he sent me this
schedule and he was basically it was
supposed to be an excel sheet yeah
and in this excel sheet I said hey he
goes I was like hey if you guys want to
work out ideas that you're trying to
pitch me on can you go let's let's work
out these these things that we need on
an excel sheet and then we can fill it
in together and then we can work in that
way because you guys I'm based in LA you
guys are based across across country so
let's figure it out like that he goes
qual send you an excel sheet full sends
me an excel sheet it just says an excel
sheet that says ideas on it it was a mic
there was a [ __ ] Google Doc they said
ideas on it that's it that's just a doc
that says ideas and I got so [ __ ] mad
did he capitalize the eye at least it
was bolded and then I wrote back lol I
was like when you send me something real
let me know it was to the whole team
yeah it calls me amigos ain't like I'm
just been super [ __ ] busy like I know
I was like I could I know how to do an
excel sheet I just wanted to get it out
there so we could just hat start jotting
down is D and I remember on the phone
was like amen to do a proper excel sheet
it takes about five to six minutes yeah
at most just say you don't know how to
do a myth yeah just say you don't know
how to use Excel like that I was like
bro I have to roast you on that [ __ ]
because that's hilarious yeah because I
got he's like alright man like I'll send
you something better send me another one
trash I was like [ __ ] it so I got Mariel
to do one cuz she's a coordinator
sending one I was like this is what I'm
expecting right sent it out you know
kind of embarrasses him in front of a
few people yeah so I don't know he
doesn't like me and then later on he
does something yeah he pulls another
[ __ ] stunt well on the excel sheet I
wrote a bunch of [ __ ] ideas right and
then while he's doing this in a group
chat with a bunch of people who are
under him and some people were above him
all the ideas that I wrote on the excel
sheet he goes he goes hey so I got this
great idea right and he starts prattling
all these ideas that were my ideas that
excel sheet and in the conference call I
remember I said that's called like so
cool so you read it so you're basically
reading out loud what I wrote yeah he's
like dead silent so he's calling how I
mean he didn't think that you would
realize actually I was like so this is
why I ever made it look like
so you're basically reading everything I
wrote did you read my email yeah or are
you just saying this off the top of your
head because I brought this in the email
right lazy [ __ ] dead silent yeah I
think he goes Auto it's like these are
ideas that was think I was like no these
aren't your ideas yeah I was like in
every other do you guys have a computer
can you open up the excel sheet yeah
it's right there
I wrote all these ideas so you're not
seeing anything new I would slap his
[ __ ] face do you know and then he's
like stumbling over his lords right and
he clangs
after the conference calls he hangs up
after he goes in my bad man I didn't
know those were your ideas I was
thinking the same thing and I was like
bro you weren't thinking the same thing
man if you read the lying sack of [ __ ]
sounds like if you read the [ __ ]
email you know what's in there man like
come on cut that [ __ ] out I want to I
want to be in your situations just so I
could I could talk [ __ ] to people yeah
it's you know what it's it's pretty
refreshing too because like the
conference call version of what I said
to him after the conference call was a
lot nicer because I'm not trying to
[ __ ] get him fired but I would but
after but afterwards I'm a little
irritated because you can't take credit
for my [ __ ] work
yeah you know what I mean yeah so it was
like that's what I don't like about the
corporate world sometimes everybody is
just out for their own ass and they will
make sure that you drown if it keeps
their head afloat hate that this is a
toxic work culture dude I've gotten guys
fired at my company yeah it's a hotel my
hotel I would I would I would work with
my manager I'll be like hey that guy's
[ __ ] lazy yeah and I'm like why do
you keep him around and he goes aw you
don't understand Joe he has two kids and
I'm like but doesn't that make doesn't
doesn't it make sense if he has two kids
he should work [ __ ] harder it not not
be a complaining entitled little [ __ ]
like why does he get special treatment
because you feel sorry for him and he's
like I know you're right man but it's
different like you know when you have a
family I'm like nah dude III don't
respect this guy and I'm like I was like
why don't we move them to a different
department and I promise you I'll take
over his work without extra money so
he's like really you'll do that and I'm
all like yeah he's bottlenecking us so
[ __ ] hard that it's irritating me and
I'll take over his work and I can do it
I know I can because the thing is that
who he's one of those guys that he he he
tricks the system and I hate people like
this and build on my milk they'll milk
the [ __ ] thing always pretend injury
back pain all this [ __ ]
my manager is a [ __ ] sweetheart he
loves and cares for his employee to the
point where he's not smart about it he
gets taken advantage of and so I saw
this [ __ ] lazy [ __ ] doing this and
then and then always like I would see it
right after lunch he wants to [ __ ]
relax more so he's like oh man you know
like like I can I take a little extra
break cuz you know like I'm lifting
these boxes and I'm like every [ __ ]
time like clockwork
after [ __ ] lunch this guy wants to
take another 30-minute break
lazy [ __ ] while all of us work because
right after lunch we hustle hard so we
could finish early right yeah and then
I'm like I'm just wit I'm just seeing
all these like tricky little things this
[ __ ] does and I was like well if you
don't have the heart to fire him let's
just move him to a different Department
and then we got him to a different
Department I took over his work and then
I was like bro I could [ __ ] finish
mine and his work easily before lunch
yeah and I'm like he wasn't even doing
[ __ ] dude he's pretending to work taking
money away he was he was working on an
assembly line packing [ __ ] like he
milked his orders he had about eight
orders and he took them from like 9:00
in the morning all the way till 2:00
p.m.
yeah to do in these eight orders I could
fall I'll [ __ ] fill at like 11:00
a.m. yeah so it's like things like that
drive me crazy because I don't know man
I think for me I like working with the
team that gets together and we're
honorable and we [ __ ] fight hard Yeah
right and that's the type of people I
want to be around I don't want to be
around people who are [ __ ] snaky
liars cowards to me like they are the
[ __ ] of the earth so like in that
example like I would have called them
out right in front of everybody I'm like
you [ __ ] lied yeah why did you lie or
like um just recently there was this
whole fiasco I went through and I was
talking to these guys these old [ __ ]
white guys right and they try to
Hollywood me I hate when people try to
[ __ ] big dick Hollywood me and then
they'll be talking about like all the
money that's on the line and all these
stats makes me go oh my god no I
literally in the middle of their talk I
said look I don't care like I
I was like I don't care you got a lot on
the line that's fine you know what let
me just [ __ ] you know I was just like
you got a lot on the line that's fine
whatever
good for you good good good like I was
patronizing as a [ __ ] cuz I
don't talk like that yeah and I was just
in and I was like moving forward I was
like this is my point and I'm like you
got till 2:00 you gonna call me back
before that if you can't I'm not talking
to you because I have the rest of the
day [ __ ] busy alright bye
yeah and I just hang up on him that's
why I like working with the fishing
company doesn't know what they're doing
yeah
this last project that I was on that's
gonna come out next year this company is
the most badass [ __ ] streamlined
hard-working company everybody works
[ __ ] hard they get their [ __ ] done
and on top of that the the all the
higher-ups in this company are all
[ __ ] females Wow they [ __ ] kick
ass dude that's tired they get [ __ ] done
no [ __ ] they know how to have fun
while they work they but they excel at
their job we when we when we shot this
they every every time that we shot this
it just moved quicker and quicker and
quicker
oh hell yeah first episode was us
figuring it out second episode we cut it
we got an hour earlier done yeah and
then the next episode it got even
earlier and earlier one episode we got
even like an hour and a half done
earlier yeah and they just get better
every [ __ ] time everybody's
respectful they do their [ __ ] and
they're happy with their work and that's
what I love about companies like this
that's tight you know I mean it makes me
and I unlike I walked away just with
like so much respect for the company
it's like holy [ __ ] dude this is this is
a dope company man like everybody does
their part really well they're super
respectful I love any culture like that
yeah how do you think they get it done
like do you think they've cultivated a
good relationship or they you know pick
and chose I mean like what do you think
what was the magic I think what it was
too is that they hire people who know
what they're doing and it's not [ __ ]
it's not flames up their ass yeah so the
person that got removed from the last
company this was [ __ ] like four or
five years ago that guy he got removed
because he came from another from one
another company that he had a high
position in but but he bullshitted
really well so their hiring process I
feel it all starts with who you who you
have to manage the company first yeah so
they work through their own [ __ ] and
beef
had to prove themselves to be in that
position to help grow it and then they
got to be solidified so everybody had
improved their part you didn't just get
the job because of a position that you
had before somebody that you knew yeah
you left the job because you showed
numbers and so and and you know there's
I'm probably sure I don't I don't know
the company down that well but you know
they probably went through their weeding
out process too but from what I saw it
was an amazing efficient company and it
made me want to be a part of them like
anything that they would ask I would do
an instant because he care about talent
yeah I care about crew they care about
staff that's dope that's the kind of
company that's a good balance yeah
lately I've been wanting to be a oil
tycoon [ __ ] up I just make that money
yeah I just I just want literally want
to go into a board mean and be board
meeting and be like a [ __ ] 1890s oil
tycoon and be like hey you [ __ ] see ya
do you [ __ ] you know like there were
way crazier back then like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you get out of the [ __ ] room
just that like [ __ ] I want to be like
kind of nuts and I don't know man
like there's something about me that I
love combat like I know like I love
aggression and combat and confrontation
and I can't do that right now and and so
when I hear these stories I'm like I
want to be in that boardroom I want to
call out that [ __ ] employee and catch
his ass and get him kicked out yeah I
want to do company takeovers I want to
[ __ ] eat like I want to I want to and
and when I when people hear this they
might get the wrong impression right
like I'm not like this I'm exaggerating
about being the monopoly man like yeah
what I really want to do is I want to
clean up companies from stupidity mmm
from snakes from Liars from cowards from
[ __ ] milkers yeah you know people
that are taking advantage of each other
and [ __ ] like that I want to clean that
[ __ ] up and create a loving environment
where people are working [ __ ] hard
and feel purpose in the workplace yeah
and the only way to do that sometimes is
to be a cold hard killer yeah I mean
it's it's it's difficult because when
you start your company and you have to
there's just a lot of weight on your
shoulders man like and it's it's
something that could never do I think
when I was trying to expand Davis Hill
comedy and I had a beautiful butt like
three or four employees under my belt
and she's just stressed me the [ __ ] out
like I I could I lost sleep over
worrying about somebody else's job and
being able to pay them you know that's a
big part of being a boss though it's
hard man it's so [ __ ] hard and you
know I think being independent and doing
my own thing helps me out better because
I just have to worry about myself and
maybe to other people mm-hmm so it makes
it a lot easier on me yeah well that
wraps up this podcast everybody we
talked about [ __ ] YouTube [ __ ]
being broken [ __ ] and losing money and
then toxic company culture but yeah this
podcast is about anything and everything
you guys already know what's up we're
here to be with you on your everyday
commute check us out on iTunes podcast
stitcher Spotify any kind of audio
platform out there we are there every
Thursday and every Sunday we will see
you guys next time love you [ __ ]
write comments below give us those high
ratings and then you guys will see us
twice a week for the rest of your life
bling ding peace